a new report from the United Nations is
painting a grim portrait of the state of
our planet according to their global
assessment report there has been a 100%
increase in greenhouse gas emissions
since 1980 up to 1 million of the
world's species are threatened with
extinction and the human species itself
is suffering 40% of the world's
population lacks access to clean and
safe drinking water and that is just the
beginning
here to discuss the report and its
implications it's Jeffrey Kluger editor
at large at Time magazine Jeffrey good
morning good morning the numbers say it
all this does not paint a pretty picture
especially when it comes to wildlife I
mean should we be in an all-out panic we
well I'm not sure panic is a good idea
but extreme alarm I would say is is
appropriate there are a million species
on the planet and 1 million of them are
threatened with extinction within a
matter of decades now different species
are threatened in different ways we're
gonna lose or we could lose 40% of
amphibians 33% of shark species 33% of
coral forming species there are
currently more Tigers living in cages
than there are in the wild when one
timeline on this Jeffrey with a timeline
for some of these things is just on the
order of decades and that's an important
number because it is true that this
isn't all a function of our current
industrial age there has been some
native species die-off about 20% since
1900 but it's accelerated exponentially
just in the last few decades
that's wild life we also have to think
about oceans Michelle mentioned drinking
water but 71 percent of earth is covered
by water and that's really scary the
most alarming number to me was that each
year 400 million tons of heavy metals
toxic sludge and fertilizer runoff pours
right into the ocean as you said plastic
production has increased a hundredfold
that has contributed to the great
Garbage Patch in the Pacific Ocean which
is three times
the square mileage of France and that
plastic gets into fish
yeah and gets into us and the fish
themselves fifty-five percent of the
world's oceans are now open to
industrial feels like you can't undo
that you can only stop more in the
future well there is a lot that we can
do in that respect a lot of our problem
is our population there were three point
seven billion of us in 1900 there are
now seven point six billion of us we are
a hungry messy species three-quarters of
our land and 1/3 of our water goes to
producing the things that keep us alive
that defeat us who are the best global
citizens out there I mean who are the
messiest the ones who just aren't doing
another do right aren't cleaning up
their room exactly well I think we all
think that it's a little like voting we
think well you know it's not gonna make
a difference if I though right it's not
gonna make a difference if I throw my
plastic bottle away right but it will
make a difference if we all do it and I
also think look you know we were talking
earlier about partisanship it is not
partisan to say that we can't be doing
wilfully destructive things like leaving
the Paris climate Accords if we can't
lean on our current leaders to fix those
kinds of problems then we need new
leaders one of the most alarming things
about this Jeffrey though is that we
haven't really even begun to write
activist no we haven't and this is and
again it's a slow-motion catastrophe
when 9/11 happened we were hit fast we
were hit hard and we mobilized because
we get that the threat was this could
happen tomorrow afternoon at a shopping
mall so we moved but when you tell
people this is gonna happen it's gonna
happen over the course of decades and
you're gonna hurt your grandchildren
people say yeah I got work to do that's
why you see so many young young kids I'm
sure but Jarrod's teenagers getting very
proactive yeah no I know my kids are
alarmed about it yeah and we've done it
before the ozone layer we have had
look I noticed before right before I
came on I saw you're doing something
wrong on the Apollo Apollo 11 we are in
the 50th anniversary era now of the
Apollo programs this was the first time
we were able to move far enough from
Earth to see our planet for what it is
it's sort of this beautiful glass
breakable Christmas tree ornament and
we're breaking it yeah yeah all right
mouth lugar always enlightening thanks
Jeffrey thank you so much